- This can't happen again, Rob. Trade Russ, maybe a pick, and we get Kuzma and KCP.
What? Yeah, I—Duh, Rob, I know. Make the trade, Roooob!
The arena outside of space and time.
- Welcome, The King, LeBron James...
- Finally. Me and him.
I can't wait to compare Space Jams.
- ...to our first two-on-two Portal matchup.
- Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah. Two-on-two? But KD got his own—
Oh, yes. I like this. Because I am a good teammate.
- [Old-school announcer:] Versus Shaquille O'Neal.
- And me! NBA All-Star Penny Hardaway!
- All right. Let's destroy this old man.
- Whatever, man, at least I get to play with—
- [Modern announcer:] Joining LeBron is
Anthonyyyy Davis!
- Hey, LeBron! It's me, AD!
- Oh, come on. He's not even my best sidekick.
- Ha, Penny's not Shaq's best either.
- What? I'm no sidekick.
- [Modern announcer:] Y'all know the deal:
play to 11, win by two.
- I'll check Penny.
- Man, if you don't get your lanky ass down in the paint and guard Shaq.
- Barbecue chicken.
- [Old-school announcer:] Shaq hammers it home with authority.
- Damn, did that hurt?
Use Portal Cream, the only interdimensional ointment–
- [Modern announcer:] Shaq wasting no time hawking products.
- [Old-school announcer:] Shaq sent that flying into the next dimension!
- [Fan:] Damn!
- All me!
- [Modern announcer:] Shaq with the filthy handles!
- Hey, I need you to step your game up.
My legacy can't afford a Portal loss.
- Help, help!
- Aaah!
- [Modern announcer:] AD with the help D.
- You see that, LeBron? I did good, right?
[Shaq chuckles]
- Taxes complicated because you
sometimes work in space?
Try ShaqTax! Isn't that right, Lil' Penny?
- Man, I am regular Penny.
The puppet isn't 6’ f--kin' 7”!
- Look, I don't want us ending up like those two.
- If we cool, why'd you go to Disney World
without me?
- Because you can't fit on the rides!
- So if you don't want to play as a big man, that's fine.
Just be yourself. As long as it means
me getting a win.
- You might be Superman in the paint,
but you're Kazaam on the perimeter.
- You know, Shaquille, at times like this, I worry about
the 1990's Orlando Magic dynasty.
Thanks.
- [Old-school announcer:] Oh! Shaq
with the follow slam!
- [Modern announcer:] That bucket puts them back within one.
- I'm open!
- I'm Shaq. Ah!
- [Old-school announcer:] And now, game point!
- AD!
- [Modern announcer:] LeBron and AD pull off an improbable win!
- Must be nice in L.A. Tons of media opportunities.
- I have one eyebrow and I keep getting offers.
- Later, Penny. I'm going with them.
- Shaq, you son of a b---h.
- Wow, I am a team player.